angry ben is always a fun ben glad to
have our first guest you know him of
course host of the ben shapiro show on
the daily wire now nationally syndicated
you can follow him
at ben shapiro so he can take it out on
you and not just me
ben why are you such why are you such an
angry jew today
god dang it who booked this why am i
even here
oh god not crowder this day's long
enough
ah what's what's so rough with your day
you look like you've done a lot of
percocet like there's a glass
in your eyes yeah it's just it's been a
long day man it's been a long day i
can't even talk about some of this stuff
on the air i mean i killed a guy
that was my thing i probably shouldn't
have said on the air yeah for a smart
guy you let that one slip pretty quickly
yeah yeah you're fiddling polish this is
why my lawyer says i shouldn't talk to
the cops but
yes exactly and now that it's already
out there like president trump i will go
talk to robert mueller just as much as i
please well okay
thank you very much let's so is it is it
just personal stuff or is it stuff
that's going on in the news that has you
so pissed off oh no it's the
the news the news is fine i mean
honestly like the news the news is
better than fine i i
like president trump is doing excellent
things on the foreign policy front which
is which is great
he has he has this interesting view of
the world president trump where
everybody is a winner or a loser
yeah and that doesn't work well in
economics because there can be mutual
winners when you and i are trading
products and services
but it does work really well on foreign
policy it turns out because it turns out
that if iran loses everybody wins
yes and so that's been so that's been
really good i just got done saying
right before this what's wrong with
being i said people will often say well
that's reductive
what's wrong with being reductive with a
nation that commits gross violations of
human rights when they don't have a
nuclear arsenal remember
there is no middle ground again this is
the part that's hilarious to me is
everybody's like well you know that iran
nuclear deal was preventing them from
getting a nuclear weapon and
those moderates they were really being
emboldened by the nuclear deal it's like
well you know what if they want to be
moderate you know what they could do
they could just give up their nuclear
weapons like without a deal that's
exactly
stop funding terrorism in fact i did i
did an entire piece on this yesterday
at my website daily wire where we talked
specifically
about the i'm sorry about that but you
know just because we're
wildly more successful than anything
else this is absolutely true there's no
doubt about it because you employ slave
labor it's amazing what you can do with
children at computers in bangladesh
well i mean you're wondering why i had a
bad day our contract just got
tossed in the garbage but in any case
but one of the
one of the things i'm saying is that
there are only a couple of nations in
human history that have had nuclear
weapons or were developing nuclear
weapons and gave them up
one was in 1993 south africa gave up
their nukes yeah and the other was in
2003 qaddafi gave up his
incipient nuclear program both of them
did so as a show of good faith to the
world it wasn't that we came along and
said here's a bunch of money
now will you give up their nukes because
that would be stupid then they would
just say well i'll keep the money and
develop my nukes
right instead it was a bunch of regimes
attempting to moderate themselves first
and then as a symptom of that moderation
they were saying
here's our nukes so trying to say that
iran was going to moderate because we
gave them a bunch of cash is stupid if
they wanted to moderate and have a bunch
of cash they could do so without any
agreement
at all right well it's it's a you know
comparison would be a plea
plea bargain for talking about south
africa if you talk about gaddafi versus
sort of uh kramer versus kramer dustin
hoffman with the kid in the ice cream
tub just saying
don't you do it don't you do it that's
the big difference there is a big
difference one occurred before
and one occurred after and here's the
thing like i just talked about we're not
nuking them we're not buying them
we're just not going to do business with
them we're just going to isolate them
i mean even liberal parents just make
their kid have a timeout or put them in
the corner we're not even spanking them
and let's be real about this it is
providing israel the option to spank
them which i think is a
good option it's probably providing this
newfound alliance
of israel saudi arabia egypt jordan uae
the capacity to actually fight back
against iranian aggression because what
the iran deal really did mostly was it
said to any of those nations if you do
anything against iran you're in breach
of this agreement
you've destroyed world peace by trump
saying listen this agreement's no longer
here then it becomes very clear who are
the violators of the
of the peace in the middle east and that
was obvious for anybody who had half a
brain anyway since iran has taken over
syria they've now taken over lebanon
they've taken over
most of iraq they've taken over uh
they've taken over yemen uh
they've taken over the gaza strip too i
mean for the amount of funding they're
giving to hamas
like what exactly like why was this
controversial in the first place i will
say
to obama's credit it was barack obama
who created the alliance of saudi arabia
egypt jordan
israel and the uae he did so completely
unintentionally just like every other
good thing he did unintentionally
but this was mostly obama's doing
because by kissing iran's ass
he put everybody else in a position
where they had to suddenly ally with
each other in order to face down iran
yeah but you know that's very temporary
and if we look back and something
happens no one's going to blame the
alliance that you just mentioned they're
just going to blame the jews
yep that's just the way it goes
you're wondering why i'm having a bad
day every day is to blame the jew day
that's just the way it goes right now
we were just talking about that when
you're talking about you're talking
about uh obviously the uh
listen israel gave up lane in defense of
war this is where people talk about
they're like are your p i know that i'm
not paid by the jews i would take the
money and i would talk about big jew
money but when you talk about syria
jordan egypt and they said we're gonna
wipe them off for being
jews i'm amazing you didn't just take
all their stuff but my point is
in the realm of history they'll look
back and listen let's be honest do we
really think that saudi arabia and
israel are going to be allies for a long
time
no i think jews could be left holding
the bag long term which is always what
worries me with these temporary
alliances they never last with islamic
countries
i mean i think that's true but i also
think that this is the best position
israel has been in its entire history
insofar as there are now a bunch of
states that are suddenly saying you're
our allies you're not our enemies i mean
the saudi arabian leader muhammad bin
sultan
literally said to the palestinian
leadership take the deal that's on the
table or sit down and shut up and that's
an amazing amazing thing
and it also demonstrates by the way how
a lot of these countries were using the
palestinians as pawns for so long
because they obviously don't care about
enough that they don't care about this
stuff enough to actually
abide by their previous principles it
was always a ruse it was always we're
going to use this as a club against the
jews well now it turns out we need to
use the jews as a club against the
iranians so that goes immediately by the
wayside well that's my point
pragmatically they're in the best place
that they've been in a while but doesn't
it make you a little bit leery
uh just to trust someone with the name
muhammad
how many jewish israelis are named
probably not many that's a weird
question i'm sure
not a lot of jewish israelis named jesus
either this is true no i'm just saying
you know i'm just saying they're in a
good place right now i'm just i'm always
worried because that's
very temperamental but but for the for
the jews now is good yes okay if we can
think now
if we could have just taken now like
throughout human history that would have
been fine yes because it turns out that
now was usually us getting killed
so as long as we're not being killed and
they're a bunch of like temporary
alliances turns out better than no
alliances at all exactly friends
better than people attempting to kill
you so i'll take it you know i'm not
exactly next stop latkes stands across
the middle east
but you know you'll take it you take the
w at this point that's today's lesson
take the w
when you can take it um you know it's
funny that you mentioned this good
versus bad and kind of on the world
stage that being said in economics let's
kind of get rid of the tariffs and stuff
which we agree on um the the tax cut
though is remarkably popular so when you
combine that with this with foreign
policy and iran just did us a favor by
burning the american flag and they're
in their government there after the deal
was ripped it's like oh okay maybe
you're eddie haskelling it and you never
this wasn't exactly the the portal to
peace um
do you think this spells potentially
re-election for donald trump tax cuts
possible i mean
the foreign policy if if it were just
policy then the answer would be clearly
yes right i mean 57
of americans now say that the country is
moving in the right direction it's
almost impossible to see a situation
where somebody does not win reelection
under those circumstances the economy
continues to boom
uh the tax cuts are very popular the the
regulatory cuts are having a solid
impact on businesses
he's seeing success in his north korean
negotiations so far he's seeing his
success in
in in creating this this saudi egyptian
israeli jordanian alliance
all of this stuff is really really good
okay and so on policy
it's very hard to argue with the results
that president trump's administration
has been getting
the real question is going to be every
election is between two people
and unfortunately donald trump still is
the guy right and so
the the question is going to be when it
comes to 2020 and you see a lot of
donald trump being donald trump
are people in your to it which could
actually help him or are people going to
be
you know shocked all anew when it turns
out that there's somebody on the other
side who's not the worst candidate in
american history like
i i think that there's a solid chance
democrats will pick somebody garbagey
for 2020 because
they're just so many cases who do you
think is the likely pick or if you're
narrow it down to a field of three to
five uh if you were to say three to five
i would probably say kamala harris for
the intersectionality of it all right
uh joe biden for the for the um
you know obama and the and the stasis
and back to normalcy
you know campaign uh and maybe elizabeth
warren from the bernie wing
unless bernie runs again which would be
good i mean at this point there are no
upper age limits
to presidency of the united states i
mean the skeletons
from from holy grail are actually
filings for for super pac approval yes
yes i love how matt damon is no longer a
bitching about the actuary tables
if uh bernie sanders all of a sudden
it's all quiet on the damon front
uh okay well we do we have we have an
unbelievable show of course we just had
elon musk we have ryan bayer we have
blair white we have owen benjamin let me
assist you just mentioned north korea
um that's also a big plus this week it
like i said big stress
a little disappointed when president
trump afterwards said he was great to
these three people it's like oh just
just take
take the ball and leave but it is it is
a victory listen i mean it seems like
right yeah no question
yeah i mean there's no question that's a
victory uh it is
it is to the point where trump says that
sort of stuff where like our capacity
for outrage is now gone
because like okay so trump said
something real dumb shocker like wow
he said they were treated real nice by
north korea like that's because he says
that kind of
i'm sure that everything is magnificent
everything is the best everything is
really nice okay we get it like but
here's the bottom line
those three guys are standing on the
tarmac with trump and trump made that
happen and obama did not make that
happen so that that is a that is a
point in trump's favor now the real
question is going to be what happens in
june
right so there are a couple of
possibilities with what's going to
happen in june
you know is this going to be a situation
where trump kind of bends over backward
because he feels like he's been given
some goodies by the north koreans or is
this a situation where they're looking
to come to the table not because they
love president trump are scared by
president trump
but because their nuclear mountain just
imploded in north korea
but the fact is that they had a testing
site and that site completely degraded
it completely fell apart and immediately
they started talking with south koreans
so it's quite possible that trump could
have just become like the luckiest
president ever right that suddenly their
nuclear program just universal
unilaterally combusted it just randomly
exploded and trump's like wow look what
i did yeah and
that's fine with me i mean sure good
he's like a chauncey gardener who just
walked into the right place at the right
time in north korea's dom deloize just
running through with the set from
blazing saddles comes down like oh damn
yeah we'll talk now um which is why it's
so remarkable to me that justin trudeau
got stared down by this guy that just
you could take a sample size
of of any country i'll you know what
i'll even throw i'll even throw uh saudi
arabia to the mix and you would not find
a man intimidated by by
kim jong-un justin true trudeau is a
marvel because he for some reason played
ball
that dude is intimidated by like a table
like a butter knife i mean like
really justin trudeau has has about as
much intimidation factor
as like lena dunham clothed like there's
just not there's not a lot of
intimidation factor there
let me ask you this because i know
you're not a big fan of trump
personality-wise but you're on you have
to be on a deserted island
okay president donald trump or prime
minister justin trudeau
on a desert island yeah well i mean oh
that's the
so you thought you were having a rough
day
yeah the reason i the only reason i'd
say trudeau is because you could take
all of his stuff and leave him to die
make him your coconut right
exactly like it's just the two of us and
it's up to survival
like i feel like trump's trump's big but
he's i think a scrappy fighter
so yeah and he's got about 100 pounds on
me and a lot of a lot of interior rage
so yes you know i i i doubt i doubt my
own capacity against president trump
stuck on a desert
island do not get between that man and
what he wants justin trudeau however as
you just say was stared down by kim
jong-un so
yeah i i feel i have a slightly better
shot with with uh with
like i could appeal to his feminine side
or some such yes exactly or you could
challenge him to a pull-up contest and
then when he loses
uh just force him to be your indentured
servant
i know he's he's he's ripped i mean he's
one of these guys no he's skinny fat he
is he has the body of a pregnant woman
without the bump
it is it is absolutely a shame i forgot
i was talking i forgot i was talking to
mr atlas over here stephen chris yes
charles atlas
that's because that's because someone
kicked sand in my face and then i did
the isometrics that i bought in the back
of a comic book but you're pretty you're
a pull-up machine
a crossfit pull-up machine right did you
say you could use them like that's
exactly right i don't bench
just crossfit yeah yeah yeah i can i i
can knock out about 40 pull-ups in a row
kip-ups but that's still impressive
that's still very impressive
it's a different dynamic but listen it
is it is absolutely very impressive
and i always thought about that because
a lot of people don't know that about
you all right people can of course watch
the ben shapiro show
at the daily white it won't show through
your suit ben for a smart guy that's why
he's doing it bad choices
um it's unverifiable my friend
why do you think you think i hadn't
thought that through yes how many uh how
many how many markets are you indicated
to now the
on radio so yeah so the podcast is now
syndicated to i believe
uh 40 plus markets and we are in uh five
or six of the top ten so that's really
exciting absolutely
and it's fantastic and he's part of the
westwood one uh podcast network which
you know our free show on thursdays
we're with them now too uh so we'll see
some new sponsors pretty soon
uh mr ben shapiro at ben shapiro thanks
so much for being here i'm sorry you
were having a bad day hopefully we made
it a little bit worse
oh you made me feel so much better
steven who booked this thing